hi
everyone welcome to the session on
google trust we are part of the google
cloud trust team
and we work closely with our customers
to ensure that you can
confidently use our products and our
technologies from a trust perspective
specifically today will focus on
privacy security and compliance
both industry best practices and
regulatory mandates
data integrity operational transparency
and user control in this session we'll
walk you through
how our trust teams engages with
customers
to achieve this we have a very simple
agenda for you today
the introduction is really focused on
trust in the cloud
and how that manifests in everything
that we do
we'll then delve into the three c's and
you're probably wondering
what the three c's are without giving
too much away
we hope that we've piqued your curiosity
and then we'll wrap by sharing some
resources
on where you can find more information
about google cloud compliance privacy
and security by way of introduction
my name is ronnie irbis i lead the
enterprise trust
team at google cloud and as a team we're
responsible
for helping our enterprise customers in
highly regulated
industries with their compliance
and privacy and trust related
assessments and
implementations we work closely with our
customers globally
and additionally we assist with
customer-led audits
regulator audits which includes data
center audits
i am here with my colleague ruchi karana
and ruchi leads the google's security
risk
program and this program is focused on
ensuring
the ongoing privacy and security
of our customer data she collaborates
with many of
our highly regulated cloud
enterprise customers on engagements
related to trust security
audit and compliance
as i had mentioned i am part of the
trust team
at google and our house is built on
four pillars the first pillar is around
protection data security is
the foremost in everything that we do
it is part of our dna you've already
heard probably about our layers of
security controls our firewall
virtual private cloud service controls
cloud armor iem identity and
access management with policy
intelligence
and now the cloud security command
center premium
with security health analytics to help
with compliance and misconfiguration
detection
we've delivered additional
security functionality with recapture
enterprise and web
risk where we prevent bot attacks fake
account
creation fraud malware phishing
all that could impact our customers and
our customers end users
our second pillar really is around
transparency
the road to trust has to be built
through transparency
and that transparency has to be based on
accurate and on-demand information
and we have built and delivered features
to our customers like
access transparency access approvals
third-party key management specifically
for that reason
products that enforce customer control
which leads us to our third point
control
we live by the principle that our
customers
own their data we don't
you can access it take it out at any
time
we have built and equipped our customers
with tools and technology to manage
access
and protect their data and last but not
least is
enterprise compliance we've built
world-class capabilities to
enable and facilitate our customers
compliance
with the fast range of regulatory bodies
around the world
we invest in achieving and maintaining
our regulatory certifications and
attestations for all of our products
across all of our data centers globally
so for the purpose of today's
presentation we'll be looking at
trust through the lens of our enterprise
customer engagements
and for ease of discussion let's talk
about it from
one a compliance perspective to
a commitment perspective and three the
collaboration
angle starting with compliance
our customer-centric approach to
compliance has really enabled us to view
compliance with a much
wider perspective so if you look at the
pyramid
in front of you compliance of google
cloud
we deliver foundational certifications
as well as industry specific
certifications
that addresses multiple industry
segments such as
public sector healthcare financial
services to name a few
over the foundation is compliance in
google cloud
we deliver a comprehensive set of
capabilities
to help customers ensure that their
google cloud workloads
are always compliant compliance toolkits
where we deliver a very diverse range of
self-service compliance tools to help
our customers
assess act and comply
with their regulatory requirements
so our customers and regulators expect
as they should
independent verification of our security
privacy and compliance controls and
google undergoes
independent third-party audits on a
regular basis
to provide this assurance this means
that an independent auditor
has examined the controls present
in our data centers our infrastructure
and in operations our certifications
include widely recognized and
internationally accepted independent
security standards including
iso 27001 for security controls
2717 27017
for cloud security 27018
for cloud privacy as well as soft one
soft to stock 3
and these certifications help us meet
the demands of
industry standards also such as csa star
pci dss and many other regional
standards as well
and we continue to expand the list of
our certifications globally
to assist our customers with their very
dynamic
compliance landscape and
here's a list of some of the regulatory
authorities that
we've engaged both unilaterally and with
our industry peers
and with our customers we're also
working on
more compliance products and toolings to
help our customers streamline
and automate their compliance process
with their regulators
so moving on i'm going to hand this over
to ruchi who's going to talk about
the second c in the trust journey that
we're taking you on
over taruchi thanks rani for the
wonderful introduction
and the summary on the compliance piece
now let's talk about commitments
major part of the commitments is
transparency
a cloud provider should detail how it
operates
at google we are committed towards
providing you transparency
of our security design choices via
multiple artifacts
a few recent examples include our
overall infrastructure security
encryption at rest
and encryption and transit across our
platforms
when you have these types of detailed
documentations
you can make the decision yourself to
determine
if what we are doing for security and
privacy
is adequate
next a cloud provider should provide
binding commitments on how it will
operate
and handle your data internally these
areas of commitment should include
things like processing restrictions
business continuity
data deletion data incident notification
process
subprocessor list and other security
measures
at google we are transparent and
committed towards
all of these areas you can easily find
these commitments
on our data processing security terms
page
now let's talk about the third c that is
collaboration
and it's one of the most important c of
the trust
talking about collaboration at google we
offer
a suite of services when it comes to
collaborations
to start with we have a huge team of
specialists
who will help you to understand google's
grc posture
we offer workshops and one-to-one
sessions
with grc gurus an example would be
understanding compliance lifecycle at
google
secondly we offer free access to
google's third-party audit reports
which radi mentioned earlier such as iso
sock
fedramp and others thirdly
our teams work on multitude of security
and compliance
collaterals to help you understand
and address common security risks
last but not the least we are dedicated
towards supporting your due diligence
or third party risk efforts in the form
of facilitating your cyber security risk
assessments
next let me talk through collaboration
through audit rights
at google we are committed to meet your
regulatory
and contractual requirements of right to
audit
we offer all regulated customers
right to assess us on security controls
moreover we also offer your customers
or end users transitive right to audit
google's services and organizational
controls
secondly we understand that your
operations
may extend beyond a certain region so
we offer the right to inspect a google
data center
for physical and environmental security
controls
in whichever region you are operating
thirdly we are committed to support any
audits
that may be requested by our regulators
what we have found is that transparency
is the key when it comes to working with
regulators
and our teams will work with you and
support any request
with the utmost transparency
and finally we also offer pooled audits
where multiple institutions can pull
together as one group
to audit google services and
organizational controls
this approach benefits both google and
google customers
in terms of time resources level of
effort
and audit depths to give you an example
of pooled audits
google is committed towards supporting
ccag pooled audits for european
financial institutions these financial
institutions are required to conduct a
comprehensive risk assessment
of their cloud providers to comply with
their regulatory obligations
from regulatory bodies such as eba or
baffin etc
to optimize on time and cost of the
effort
these european financial institutions
work together as a team
in 2019 we supported google's
first ccag audit audit planning and
execution took over six months from both
the sites
auditors collected over 800 plus
documents
and 175 plus googlers from
24 different teams were involved in
supporting this audit
this shows how much committed we are to
pooled audits
and 2020 pooled audits is also coming
soon
now when we talk about auditable cloud
universe or any security program per se
there are many
areas of responsibility starting from
the base layer
of securing infrastructure to going up
in the stack of securing the network
securing data securing applications or
managing identities and access
there are also like ongoing processes
for security operations
governance risk and compliance
management
at google we provide capabilities to
audit
all the domains that are relevant for
your business operations
we have a global team who can support
you in any region
be it america's europe japan asia
pacific
we collaborate with local teams on both
policy and industry
to better understand the regulations
that you are subject to
so that we can provide the highest level
of services
when it comes to facilitating these
audit requests
now here are some additional resources
for you to learn more about
google's security compliance and trust
posture
and offerings thank you so much for
listening to us today hope you learned
about how google cloud is building trust
through compliance commitment and
customer collaborations
thank you thank you so much
you